j'avais juste envie de fermer les yeux
que ça s'arrête et enfin d'être en paix
hello c'est Aurélie Preston j'ai 30 ans
et vous m'avez connu dans les
télésalités je suis née dans le 93 à
Saint-Denis dans un hôpital assez
glauque
malheureusement pour moi je n'ai pas eu
la chance d'avoir des parents à cause de
leurs addictions l'héroïne c'est quelque
chose de très difficile quand on plonge
dedans en général on en sort pas c'est
quelque chose qui aspire qui prend toute
l'énergie possible d'un être sa vie son
confort de vie son argent au point de
complètement délaisser sa famille mon
père une fois avait vendu tous les
meubles dans l'appartement de ma mère on
vivait avec mes parents dans un
appartement où il logé des dealers et
aussi des consommateurs ma mère a
commencé l'héroïne pendant qu'elle était
enceinte de moi donc j'ai eu pas mal de
soucis de santé à la suite de ça j'ai dû
prendre des hormones de croissance quand
j'étais jeune j'ai une bradycardie et
j'ai eu un râle au poumon j'ai failli
mourir donc ma grand-mère a tout fait
pour me récupérer au tribunal de Bobigny
et là j'ai enfin pu savoir ce que
c'était en fait d'avoir un parent j'ai
découvert ce que c'était la musique j'ai
connu éducaf et Elvis Presley la danse
le chant et grâce à ça je me suis
enfermée dans ma dans ma petite bulle en
fait ça m'a permis en fait de pallier à
énormément de choses et à énormément de
traumatismes comme le fait de ne jamais
avoir dit papa déjà j'avais vécu un peu
le harcèlement en primaire parce que
j'étais un peu la fille de personnes le
fait aussi que j'étais trop avenante
j'étais tout le temps en train d'être
dans l'empathie avec les autres de
vouloir tout faire pour les autres de
vouloir être aimé de vouloir avoir
l'amour que j'ai pas eu en fait chez moi
quand j'arrive au collège en fait
ça s'amplifie vraiment parce que je suis
hyper proche d'une fille et cette fille
là en fait fait des castings avec sa
mère pour devenir chanteuse modèle etc
et je l'accompagnais tout le temps en
fait sur les castings jusqu'au jour où
il y a un caster qui dit moi je suis
intéressé par la fille
ma grand-mère était banquière donc son
ancien chef lui dit bah si tu veux moi
j'ai une chambre qui est disponible pour
Aurélie il y a pas de souci je le fais
volontiers en plus c'était trop bien
parce que c'était juste à côté de
l'école donc je commence à aller là-bas
en fait je dormais sur une chauffeuse au
sol dans le bureau donc j'étais épuisé
c'était très difficile pour moi et puis
la nuit il commençait à venir me voir
dormir donc je commençais à avoir peur
et je le disais ma grand-mère donc elle
est venue me récupérer et là le mec a
pété un plomb et il a sorti une arme
pour que je reste avec lui là ça a été
encore une fois trouvé un appartement
continuer les cours en même temps en
plus j'étais arrivé en cours d'année
donc c'était très difficile l'école de
danse parce que je voulais vraiment
rattraper le niveau des autres sauf que
manque de bol je me blesse gravement à
la danse et la Clinique du Sport me dit
que je pourrais plus danser et qu'il
faut que j'arrête à ce moment là je
vivais en fait dans dans un studio de 9
mètres carrés et c'était très difficile
parce que j'avais 1 euro pour trois
jours pour manger ma grand-mère me dit
on peut pas payer le studio la
nourriture tout ça donc hop encore une
fois on repart à zéro et là j'arrive
dans le sud là je me dis qu'est-ce que
je vais pouvoir faire j'ai commencé à
travailler dans le milieu de la nuit
et là j'ai clairement explosé en fait
j'étais là danseuse la plus connue de
France j'allais danser à Londres à
Jakarta Miami enfin c'était dingue et là
en fait on me propose pour la énième
fois la téléréalité parce qu'on me
proposait depuis que j'avais 16 ans en
fait je suis partie pour aller
rencontrer justement les castors et en
gros ils me disent bon bah on te prend
direct voilà tu pars dans une semaine
non c'était même pas une semaine sous
trois jours et donc j'arrive en
Thaïlande j'ai toujours refusé en fait
la télé parce que déjà ma grand-mère
était totalement contre deuxièmement
c'était pas du tout un plan de carrière
pour moi à la suite de ça donc j'arrive
en Thaïlande je connaissais déjà Julien
je connaissais déjà Kim puisqu'on avait
travaillé ensemble dans le milieu de la
nuit je connaissais Jessica elle avait
un copain qui était sur Montpellier donc
je l'avais déjà croisé etc et je les
connais c'est à peu près tous en fait
sauf que pour eux on était les nouveaux
et en gros on n'avait pas notre place là
on devait leur laisser en place on
m'avait demandé de d'arrêter de chanter
en fait de renoncer à mon projet pro
pour que une candidate puisse chanter on
me disait non mais faut pas que tu
fasses comme ça il faut que tu sois
drôle faut que tu sois un peu comme
Nabilla et là tu vas exploser sauf que
moi je suis intègre avec mes valeurs et
avec ce que je suis moi j'étais
tellement à fond parce que je voulais
tellement réussir dans la musique il me
promettait justement derrière un single
plein de choses etc donc je me suis mis
à fond quand je termine ce tournage en
fait je me rends pas compte de l'impact
que ça puisque je regarde pas la
téléréalité et je regarde même pas la
télé tout court et donc je rentre en
France je me rends compte en fait que là
ça ça devient dès que je vais au centre
commercial c'est des émeutes en plus de
ça j'avais fait un buzz sans le vouloir
par rapport à mes lèvres une candidate
m'avait appelé boustiflor donc ça avait
tourné de partout et après bah je suis
démarché par la concurrence donc les
anges au début je voulais pas le faire
et puis me vendre du rêve non mais
Aurélie on va faire de toi la nouvelle
Lady Gaga tu vas avoir un bus énorme
rien que pour toi avec des danseurs ma
vie c'est la musique donc je me dis ok
pourquoi pas quelle erreur j'ai fait ça
a été horrible j'ai pas de mots pour
pour décrire ça j'ai jamais voulu
regarder en fait les épisodes je voyais
juste ma grand-mère qui pleurait au fur
et à mesure il y a eu des critiques
quand je faisais le sport des critiques
sur ma voix des critiques sur mon
physique on essaie de me faire passer
pour une fille qui est intéressée par
les mecs qui sont en couple alors que
pas du tout pour parler justement de
cette fameuse personne et de ce fameux
couple c'était mon ami en fait je le
connaissais d'avant et il connaissait
même mon ex j'avais tout fait pour qu'il
rentre dans le tournage donc quand en
fait bizuté et vraiment fait la misère
pour je quitte le tournage j'étais juste
écœuré c'était de la trahison on me dit
tu seras comme dans les Marseillais la
victime on va tout faire pour que tu
partes
sauf que en fait si je partais je
renonçais au projet professionnel et la
production quand il s'est passé tout ça
en fait elle a même pas réagi ils ont
juste demandé aux candidats de sortir
dehors et de s'excuser il m'a même pas
regardé dans les yeux il a dit ouais
vas-y c'est bon là je m'excuse d'après
ça j'ai attaqué la production parce
qu'en plus de ça malheureusement j'ai
même pas touché mes droits sur les deux
morceaux que j'ai fait pour eux donc le
générique plus le morceau que j'avais
enregistré pendant le tournage ça a duré
5 ans j'ai gagné les deux procès ça a
été très long j'ai reçu des menaces j'ai
pas pu chanter pendant un an j'ai dû
faire des cours en fait de confiance en
soi scénique etc parce que je n'avais
plus du tout confiance en moi et puis
moi quand je suis rentrée ma famille ma
mère t'es qu'une de télé-réalité voilà
quand elle est alcoolisée elle est
horrible avec moi horrible et en fait
j'en voyais jamais la fin et puis en
plus de ça bah pendant toutes ces années
ces images horribles ma sœur elle est
handicap à 50% et c'est une personne
qu'il faut tout le temps accompagner
qu'il faut aider financièrement ma mère
aussi mon frère je lui parle pas il
s'enferme en fait chez ma mère et pareil
il boit et moi en fait je suis là et
j'essaie de d'aider tout le monde et
financièrement et d'être un soutien pour
tout le monde parce que quand ma mère
m'appelle et qu'elle me dit si ce soir
je meurs c'est de ta faute je me
suicider des fois on m'appelle oui aller
dans un parc public au sol donc je dois
aller la chercher dans un parc public au
sol la ramener chez nous elle nous
frappe ma grand-mère moi en fait
j'essaie de faire mon maximum pour tout
le monde sauf qu'il y a personne qui
pense à moi entre tout ce que j'ai pu
subir dans ma vie et notamment cette
année j'avais plus plus envie en fait
tout était préparé mes dernières volonté
les codes bancaires tout ce qu'il
fallait pour justement en plus continuer
de gagner de l'argent à travers moi pour
ma mamie j'avais juste envie de fermer
les yeux que ça s'arrête et enfin d'être
en paix aujourd'hui je suis là pour pour
Mamie et pour vraiment faire passer un
beau message essayer justement d'aider
les gens qui souffrent de harcèlement
parce que malgré tout la télé par
mimétisme par justement transposition en
fait les jeunes se reconnaissent dedans
et donc refont pareil à l'école et donc
après ça évolue au lycée au travail etc
etc et justement quand je vois ce que
j'ai pu vivre en télé aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de me battre aujourd'hui je dirais
qu'en fait avoir fait ce livre briser ça
a été une thérapie voilà quand je suis
sortie de l'hôpital j'ai eu plusieurs
propositions et j'ai vachement accroché
avec une personne qui s'appelle lou ça
m'a beaucoup beaucoup aidé à pallier à
pas mal de souffrance mais on se soigne
pas comme ça là cette nuit ça a été nuit
très difficile j'essaie de remonter la
pente et justement en fait plus je
reçois d'amour de la part des gens et
plus je suis heureuse pour l'instant les
projets c'est le livre refaire de la
musique parce qu'en fait j'avais
enregistré énormément de musique pendant
le confinement
j'aimerais bien justement pouvoir
peut-être me rendre dans des écoles dans
des lycées aussi dans des EHPAD parce
qu'on ne pense pas aux personnes âgées
mais elles subissent aussi le
harcèlement en fait il y a tout type de
harcèlement il y a des gens qui
m'écrivent qui ont envie de se suicider
j'essaie justement bah de leur répondre
sur Instagram et de leur donner foi en
fait et de leur dire regardez moi je
suis encore là et je m'accroche aussi
tous les jours donc accrochez-vous avec
moi